it's been a couple of years since we've
seen a packed mother's day weekend right
but as things return to normal so are
businesses and they're ready for this
special day madison kimbrough stopped by
a local eatery to see how they're
preparing she joins us live in henderson
tonight with more madison
mother's day might officially be
tomorrow but here at the stove envy they
are in full swing
we came in here and it was really packed
the place was completely just filled
with people open for four years near the
anthem area of henderson owner john baez
says businesses from last year doesn't
even compare to this year with them
being completely booked for mother's day
with over 400 reservations last may they
did half of that with several
restrictions still in place like social
distancing and capacity limits i think
we're pretty much
far long enough to to get that back up
and running seven days especially with
the demand gearing up for almost double
probably of what we did last year
but we know we have we definitely have
more staff now
and we've
found things to do found ways to do
things more efficiently that definitely
helps us with our execution
the stove is booked tomorrow a scene
that will no doubt repeat at places all
across the valley so calling ahead is
really your best option and with these
restrictions lifted now more places will
be open for longer hours so make sure
that you just call ahead or if you're
going to these restaurants walk in and
hopefully you can get a seat reporting
in henderson madison kimbrough live
local now